how are you both doing
we're talking about metropolis so as
much as we want to talk about
the suicide squad if you'd like to talk
about a 1927
german expressionist film instead we're
here um
are you talking about the fact that they
have put together like a cut of the
movie
that is very close to what originally
fritz lang had
i saw it i just watched it two nights
ago
fascinating i'm at babelsberg studios
right now i'm in an office because i'm
filming a movie here
so i was telling margo i'm i'm upstairs
from where fritz
shot metropolis honestly i would love to
talk about metropolis but um my audience
will [ __ ] kill me
i would just say that if you haven't if
you haven't seen the movie
you absolutely should see the movie
because also what he accomplished in the
20s
it's crazy that's what i'm saying i'm
like there must have been a lot of cash
floating around in germany at the time
so how on earth did they do that i mean
it's just
yeah people don't realize i mean that's
before computer
he did that in camera it's crazy it's
crazy
so jumping into first of all i
absolutely love the suicide squad
it is such a home run it doesn't make
sense it's so
so good uh i'm sure you're hearing that
from everyone
what i love the most about this movie is
uh james's script
every scene takes a left turn you're not
expecting for both of you
what did you love about the script and
what are you excited for people to see
i loved that he just broke all the rules
immediately i mean he started killing
people
within five minutes of the film and i
was like oh [ __ ]
there aren't any rules this is like the
wild west i don't know what's gonna
happen i mean
reading the script for the first time i
was like i i don't know
there doesn't seem to be any rules this
could go in any direction and i'm
on the edge of my seat and i'm kind of
scared
warner's allowed him to just take off
any
cuffs whatsoever and just go full tilt
james gunn
to the wall like this is the james gunn
of
his early career all the way to his you
know incredible achievements
in the mcu and seeing all of that on
full display with all of the
depth and life experience and everything
that all these past few years have
brought into
all of our consciousness it's like man
it's it's a
it's a feat it is an incredible feat and
i think it's the perfect film
to rally everybody too to gather back
and
see something on the giant screen that's
gonna blow your mind and
you know touch your heart i love
learning about the behind the scenes
of the making of a movie uh learning
stuff you just don't read in the press
notes and you don't hear about
for each of you guys what can you share
that might surprise
fans to learn about the making of the
movie just how much was done practically
i mean the sets i think the sets were
some of the biggest sets built
at least in a long time um
now that we're talking about metropolis
i'm just like i guess the agreement's
probably built into good sets but
anyways
um how much was gun practically made
such a difference for us
i mean when we were shooting it we had
tons of water
and we had like being like thrown on us
and we had
buildings collapsing and we had real
palm trees and real beach and real
explosions and
like everything almost everything
saved for a giant starfish was practical
and that was
it's incredible but it also like i think
it translates on screen i think in this
day and age where you assume so much has
done cgi
i mean i think you can feel on screen
that this is
you know we were really in it it was
amazing yeah it blew my mind when i
stepped on set and i saw
all of the things that james was going
to do physically and tangibly for us as
actors to interact with that there's a
jungle i mean there's an entire jungle
that he and beth nicholson built on a
stage at pinewood studios in atlanta
and we're traipsing through a freaking
jungle it was like there's
moisture in the air i mean it was
absolutely incredible
and um yeah i can't wait i cannot wait
for people to see
um where harley is right now too because
it's so cool
this character that we all love so much
um i think what's getting james gunn's
touch on
on harley is like so cool
yeah i gotta stop there i'm gonna say
congrats again on the movie and yeah
harley has two scenes in this that fans
are gonna go bat [ __ ] over
i heard sorry bonding with polka dot man
and
i don't know any yeah you're right uh
thank you uh good luck with the rest of
the day and yeah people should watch
metropolis movies amazing
we're promoting metropolis and the
suicide squad